sorry for uh sorry to hold it delays
let's finish on it this is you should
have access three seat there and when we
can't question is 17 now this cool part
the first people eyes are really simple
and then everyone asks me questions
about 5 cm deep by few huh lots of
questions just based on my earlier
survey probably means you haven't gone
up to this question it's at that time
okay so let's say you see what scenario
parallel tracks level with each other
it's fine zero so this is moving with
velocity V equals mass and he knew it
was me because that okay now let's talk
they start pretty simple so the first
question is room is moving faster
initially and by how much
so you've got your two expressions for
velocity and that's all you need and
just try to do something values so when
you hear the word initially what does
that mean about your conditions equal
zero
so when T equals here I've got my
expression for Thomas's velocity and for
Henry so I'm just going to substitute in
T equals zero the velocity of Thomas is
20 on what you did to the answer say
meter per second
yes that's G seconds in relation is
there any way 28 units how us is Henry
going to element when you look at
Henry's velocity function right what
kind of function is it it's a constant
function right it's independent of time
so he's going at five okay let's go
beats per second 5 meter per second all
the time so usually because
traditionally by how much it's up Thomas
why if they do the second so pretty easy
so far
now huh B find the displacements are the
two trainings if they start at the
origin so what we gonna do key if we can
have velocity and we've got displacement
what's that next step what's our first
step
integration great so let's take Thomas
at Austin first
the displacement of Thomas is related to
the integral of 20 on TV plus one is
respect to time now by the way I do
recommend that you don't sit up straight
tune into it I wrote that down Mike or
myself this is especially important
because you've got different kinds of
displacement in this kind of scenario
right that's all the time so don't just
have an interval just popping out of
their way why would you want people to
do that what is perfection what an equal
to right tell me
so this function was Infinite it's gonna
be a lot of function if you didn't see
that straight away it might help you to
just slap that 20 which is just a
constant it's not fun
and you can see what you're integrating
is in the form F - okay so this is what
you get after changing rooms right when
you differentiate in the log function
so therefore what I'm going to get into
here backwards so you're getting 20 wall
2 plus 1 plus my constant good now they
also give us an initial condition they
say they both start the origin closing
okay so you say when T equals 9 then you
must ensure couples you must when T
equals 0 is displacement is also equal
to 0 therefore that's his dispatch
center then exit 8 is 20 more 0 +44 see
how he had that one now you can say
therefore see publisher said c1 because
I'm going to get
so there's my displacement function it's
just a lung function let's say we wanted
Henry he's pretty simple the
displacement of Henry okay it's just a
big eagle off his velocity so plays out
in much the same way you can see from
the record owners you still have to find
what the person is but the US you should
get the end and obvious is
so aunt Edie's interactive animated
possibilities all right that was
probably now see is where it starts to
get interesting
okay so let's write the question use
your calculator to find during which set
in the train the level and find spirit
which the trains are Oracle plot at the
end of the second all right how do you
leave discretion there community two
parts to it right number one you have to
find the time during which step another
change level and then number two you
have to find a speed right so I'm going
to be stopping for T and then I'm going
to substitute that into velocity
function of some kind right so being
that we can solve them one at a time
until you firstly use your calculator to
find during which second the trains are
level okay
during which secondly trains a level so
now what if they're at the same spot
down here's what happens you think I
think he's my he's my displacement
enormous he's my displacement I'm
hearing so all of them to be in the same
spot so most people did want to say if I
want their displacements to be the same
I like this and that's the brightness
you sort of pause from tickets and then
start scratching your head because log
function then your function just
techniques there's a kind of like thirds
of different places and you can
and anyway there's no fancy
factorization about how to read creaks
you can play with this at least allow
them to work at any technologies which
is why I have to go back to the question
read it it says use your calculator to
find yeah use your calculator so what
does it calculator have to do with any
of this
and so quick announcer plots of
nervously now stuff for seconds people
often say ok look I'll get my calculator
I'm gonna solve this I'm just gonna move
sighs I'm going to move this five T over
here which means that but even when you
have this you start to work with it the
question I got sent to me three times is
we heard some answers but and he's the
problem
so nobody busy treating is completely
hard to break right you know here's the
equations integrate evaluate and so on
so the reason why you're asking what
does it mean is because you just think
it is to visualize right so what you
need to do is picture okay by the way
for any other horse enthusiasts that is
Thomas unfortunately I don't have a
Henry that's actually Percy I was hungry
people we're going to swap you take it's
a number six and Hippocrene so just what
are we gonna do for me Jesus
okay right
researchers
okay now I say reply time right yes the
displacement W drives okay now I'm gonna
enlist your help surrender my calculator
let me do this song second murky it's
over sisters regiment because it's
involved it's involving a wall function
okay you're going to need your chocolate
up it's it's a workout with the a key so
can I get your start filling this out
but as you do that think about the
second very hard K recent question is
just a linear function right so you
start at the origin remote start so
that's me that's moving them yeah he's
gonna move at a break for a second right
so we doing this so this part here is
requested easy to calculate
okay first second was yeah let's do to
one decimal place all about that's about
that's what that one's gonna fit yeah
sorry how much okay equals to 80
okay so that gives secrecy
myself
yes
32.2
yeah okay Jackie will see you alive Oh
35.8 okay six
okay 41.6 41.6
and eight
46:21 second
yeah it seems that 48 48 okay
was that pretty simple now I'm ended up
and one
let's just get insane
15:49 alright